if you understand the steps that I'm
about to share with you in this video
you will be able to step by step create
a fortune if you don't know who I am I
cross 100 million net worth when I was
32. we have a portfolio at
acquisition.com that is 200 million
dollars a year and I have nothing to
sell you it took me way too long to
learn how fortunes are built if you
imagine the amount of people that you
have sold in your lifetime and whatever
business you have whatever it is side
hustles gigs anything and you were to
instead add up all of them together and
then they continued to pay you month
over month over month at whatever price
you sell stuff at how much bigger would
your business be if it were mine a lot
bigger my first big business was called
gym launch gym launch to date has 5 000
brick and mortar gyms that have
purchased the licensing from it if I had
5 000 of those gyms still paying right
now that company would be worth over a
billion dollars that company is probably
worth now close to about 100 million so
I've missed out on about 900 million
dollars during my career just from that
one company alone because it took me so
long to learn what I'm about to share
with you the big problem that most
people have when they are starting their
business is that they are in the selling
business not in the reorder business
they don't have recurring Revenue they
have one-time sales when you see these
merch drops and these things where
people are just selling crap and they
get the one-time purchase and no one
buys again the reason they can't make
money is because they have no
compounding vehicle what that means is
that if I sell somebody today I want to
get credit for that person that I sold
today in a year because what happens is
if you don't have that then you're
always selling for tomorrow you're
always selling for the paycheck this
month you're always selling to pay rent
rather than benefiting from a sale you
made 10 years ago and having that person
still pay you today because the thing is
that you need to harness time the people
who understand wealth understand time if
time is a liability against you it means
you're thinking like a poor person for
the wealthy time becomes an asset
because the longer you wait the more you
win if you imagine a business as a wall
of glue and you're blowing people at it
if you never even increase the amount of
people you sell let's just say you sell
one person a week in 10 years you'd have
500 customers every month who pay you
and if you have any price point that is
reasonable that is a lot of money that
is a fortune and the reason people don't
have that happen is because they don't
get it and they're only thinking about
the short sale for tomorrow the easiest
question that I like to ask when we're
analyzing one of the businesses that
we're thinking about purchasing and is
there a way that we can get someone to
buy this and never stop paying for it is
there a way that we can make this so
good the moment their card changes or
they get a new credit card they call us
ahead of time because they don't want to
stop receiving value if your phone gets
changed your phone carrier and your
credit card goes out what do you do you
call your phone card you replace it
because the value is there if your
credit card goes out what do you call
Netflix you're gonna make sure that your
car goes through if your utilities go
out because your car doesn't go through
you [ __ ] pay it if your rent doesn't
go through you make sure that it's paid
on time because these are things you
cannot live without the goal is to
figure out a way to make our value so
high that people don't want to stop dot
Peg you want to be in the reorder not
the order business there are recurring
Revenue businesses and reoccurring
Revenue so this applies whether you have
a subscription business or you have a
one-time purchase business the point is
that people come back Facebook is a
massive company they do not have a
recurring Revenue model they have a
reoccurring Revenue model meaning I go
to the Facebook store today I buy some
eyeballs and tomorrow I might go back
again and buy more eyeballs I don't have
a subscription but I reorder over and
over and over again the question that I
ask the portfolio company is that when
we're trying to grow them early on and
really get the product to be exceptional
is if tomorrow you could not Market
anything you could not get any new
customers whatsoever and the only thing
you had were the customers you have
today and any new customer that you get
could only come from referral and word
of mouth of the people you have right
now how differently would you treat them
how different would their experience be
and how much better would your product
be if the only way you can get new
customers was them sending new business
your way when you start thinking like
that that you start thinking like the
wealthy not like the poor we're always
in a rush for the next sale the next
paycheck because the reality is you
don't get customers to make sales you
make sales to get customers it's an
important distinction we only transact
in order to create the relationship so
that we can have Revenue again and again
and again you want that customer to
exist like a node of Revenue in your
business that pumps money your way month
after month after month so the big issue
is that the stuff that most people sell
sucks they're constantly focused on
promotion they're constantly trying to
find the next Customer because they
haven't confronted the real issue is
that you're just not that good and
that's okay but the problem is that
you're not focusing on the hard work
which is getting better there are three
steps that you look at when you're
actually trying to scale a business you
want to go to zero to a million make a
couple million bucks a year you can just
promote and sell [ __ ] all day long and
never build real well for me I want to
build a fortune and the only way to
build a fortune is to get people to
never stop paying you if that is our
goal we only need to learn how to
promote as much as we just need people
to start trying our product the point of
making the first sales is to get
customers the point of those first
customers is to give you feedback and
you keep getting feedback and not even
caring too much about how hard you're
marketing because the goal is to get the
product and service better and better
and better and this is why most people
can't scale because they start selling a
little bit and say oh I should promote
even more but the problem is they never
fix the product they keep selling more
and more [ __ ] and then what happens is
if you sell 100 people this month you
have to sell 100 people next month just
to maintain and then the month after
that if you up to 200 new sales a month
then the next month you have to sell 200
just to maintain but if you have 10
customers a month and they never leave
you in five years you have 600 customers
a month that are paying you only with 10
new customers a month when you get
customers who do not leave you you can
afford any marketing you can afford to
outspend everyone there's a company that
we're about to make a huge investment in
and right now their lifetime value per
customer compared to their competition
is 10x and their cost to apply our
customer
same as their competition
who's going to win in a bidding auction
for who can buy the next customer on
Facebook or YouTube or pay for the
eyeballs between them and their
competitors but win every time because
when you get that right everything else
is easy step one is you promote just to
get people to become customers promote
it so that you get the first C which is
consumption the second piece is that
actual Improvement Loop what happens is
when their business gets hard when they
hit a plateau when people can't grow
anymore they do one of two things they
start marketing more which is crazy
because it means that more people find
out about the stuff that you sell that
sucks or they create another product if
people don't consume your product people
don't consume you serve it it's not that
they're numbnuts it means that you suck
means you have created such a difficult
experience for someone to interact with
you made it so difficult for someone to
onboard that they never even experience
the benefit the amount of people that I
hear especially in the in the Internet
space who are like oh these people don't
work hard they never follow through does
Amazon complain about all the service
tickets they get no because they fixed
the price products they spent the time
to keep solving problem after problem
after problem until there were almost no
problems left with the product taking
full responsibility and saying you know
what we can make this better and the way
you do that is through surveying the
customers to figure out what you can do
better looking at their client
experience looking at the results seeing
if you can make it happen faster seeing
if you can make it happen easier making
sure that you've added so much value
that there's no one else that they can
compare your product to you keep doing
the feedback loop on those customers
until you get a product where people are
referring business to you to add the
cherry and sprinkle on top you make it
harder to leave and if you're in a B2B
situation you want to add in collateral
or controlling the money flow if you
work with stripe they probably process
your money they control the money flow
they don't worry about decline cards
because they collect your money for you
up front the person who controls the
money has leverage and then once you
crack that once you say I'm only going
to sell so that I make sales to get
customers I'm going to continue to
improve and iterate the same product
over and over and over again until the
point point where I have so many people
who are coming to me because of how good
it is then I'll put gas on it and spend
as much money as I can on the marketing
because now I can outspend everyone in
the same Marketplace I'm making 10 times
100 times more than my competitors
because when people buy from me they
don't want to stop but most people do it
in reverse news they sell as many as
they possibly can burn all the Goodwill
they have and then come out with another
product put lots of hype around it sell
a bunch of them and then do it again and
again but they cannot build a
compounding vehicle of Enterprise Value
because if every single launch if every
single customer that they had sold for
the last 10 years we're still paying
them today they would have more money
they know what to do with it's not about
the price in an absolute term it's all
relative to the value that someone
receives so if someone's price is here
and the value delivers here you can make
this price whatever you want if this
price is a million and they get 10
million in value they will pay you for
it the price is what you pay value is
what you get what we want is a customer
Surplus we want an insane deal we want a
bargain that people do call ahead of
time to make sure that they never stop
getting billed the game is saying hey
I've got a 500 000 house I'll sell it to
you for 50 Grand and I learned how to
build it for 10. even if you provide
more value up front and it's less
profitable that's okay because then
through the iterations that you have of
getting better you get more and more
efficient and you can drive down your
costs while also increasing the value
and maintaining your brand and
reputation this lesson took me seven
years to really internalize because when
I looked back at my own customer list
and I saw 5 000 locations on there I was
like I would have a billion dollar
business if I had taken more time up
front to figure out how to never lose
people